Miley Cyrus joins the area51 viral craze
with means that are out of this world
[Music]
here's the mean Miley used to kick off
her social media postings free a photo
of her and Selena Gomez dressed as
aliens flashing peace signs while on the
set of Hannah Montana the 26 year old
singer captioned the pic me and at
Selena Gomez on her way to area 51 she
also posted this photo of her dressed as
a burger while posing with someone in an
alien costume and the caption that one
time at area 51 and then there's this
one posing the question what if we
kissed at area 51 her Miley's caption
she's a bad influence even to the aliens
[Music]
and in case you've been spaced out about
all this area 51 stuff it all started
last week when a group called posting
cuz I'm in shambles created a joke
Facebook event titled storm area 51 they
can't stop all of us the post suggested
that people storm area 51 at 3 a.m. on
September 20th in order to finally see
them aliens over 1.1 million people
signed up for the event and Miley is
just one of the many to get in on the
internet fun lizzo had us cracking up
over the exclusive footage from inside
area 51 she posted to Twitter meanwhile
12 year-old Mason Ramsey tweeted this
alien FaceTime to me at 6:00 a.m. and
told me to come get him out of area 51
what should I do
[Music]
well nas ex is riding straight to the
old town raid on the highly guarded US
Air Force Base while jeffree star
tweeted he's on his way to area 51 to
warn his family about the human invasion
[Music]
meanwhile Kevin Jonas gave us this
glimpse of the hashtag happiness begins
tor at the post raid rave hashtag area51
we can't get enough of these
otherworldly memes
[Music]